well joining me now from delete Pro
Skies Chief correspondent to Stuart
Ramsey and Stuart this is extraordinary
footage uh which just adds color to an
already extraordinary incident and an
incredibly tense uh happening so close
to to the borders of this war even
though it was of course in international
airspace
yeah direct conflict between these two
countries it is very important I think
it's fair to say that when the Americans
said what had happened and we see uh in
this video that's been released two
passes on this drone and then eventually
a propeller that's not working when they
said that's what happened I think it was
fair to say that everyone knew it was
the case and that they had the video
which would support it because obviously
it's a surveillance drone so it can
actually film everything and it appears
then after that propeller was hit they
had to crash the Drone and lo and behold
the Russians are lying I think it's also
fair to say that they've been doing that
since 2014 on virtually everything to do
with Ukraine and that continues now and
it is a very much a standard procedure
now whether this leads to any escalation
it could but I suspect it won't both
sides will probably step back I think
the United States is just making the
point that we said what happened did
actually happen and we can show it bear
in mind the Russians said that there was
no contact uh with the Drone and that it
was a a pilot error by the Drone
operator not their Jets but clearly that
isn't what happened I would have to say
that the Russians have do this quite
often it's not uncommon they do very
dangerous Maneuvers in front of NATO
planes and and drones all the time it's
to unsettle the pilots rather than to
actually cause any damage because the
real fear is that one day things will go
wrong you will actually have direct
contact and then that really could
escalate but at the moment it was an
unmanned drone and I suspect this will
they'll all move on if they can and and
Stuart uh talk to us about the other
news that we're learning about this
morning as it relates to aircraft in and
around the region Poland planning to to
lend some fighter jets to Ukraine
they're going to send uh yeah um migs uh
mig-29s in the next few days four at the
start they say and there could be more
now president zelenski has been pretty
much touring the world asking uh for
fighter jets obviously tanks as well
fighter jets he really wants f-16s he's
really after so far Britain and the
United States uh have not followed that
part and say they don't really need them
at this stage so uh obviously Ukraine
believes it does uh Germany
um others will want to potentially pass
more on other countries probably will do
so as well in the future and I think
what president zelenski and Ukrainian
military will be hoping that pressure
now comes to bear on the sort of uh
United States and Great Britain with
those uh s16s and other planes Britain
has it is a significant step for them
I'm not so sure four immediately makes a
massive difference we know that tanks
are on the way now they and uh
Battlefield machines uh with them those
could be really significant uh the
fighting particularly around is
horrendous you've got to remember the
600 mile front line is active all the
time it's just that the city of black
mood is taking most of the attention and
the resources of both the ukrainians but
more importantly perhaps the Ukraine the
Russians huge numbers of men are dying
on both sides but the Russians are
losing many more because of the tactics
they're using
um Ukraine is insisting it needs to hold
on to back mood and and is determined to
do so though many think that perhaps
they don't need to but they are
determined to